well you know I was asked those
questions throughout my career in 40
years I've I think I've had about thirty
three elections counting primaries in
generals 1 25 or 26 of them so I you
know I know how to win and I'm prepared
to be President now look I know I'm an
underdog but recent polls show me just a
few points out of third place in New
Hampshire the democracy for america poll
of Internet activists the will week or
so ago I came out first in the largest
pole in the country of any of Internet
activists so look I know I'm a long shot
but you know what so are most American
people it's a long shot for people that
they're going to have their retirement
security a long shot that they'll have a
good paying job a long shot that they'll
have health care and won't go broke
paying the doctor bills a longshot their
kids will go to college I mean American
people understand long shots imagine a
long shot it becomes your president who
relates to you I mean that's what that's
why these poles can change and I just
have to move up little by little rather
you